esta es una manifestación física del
amor es glorioso y hermoso y cualquier
dios que niegue esto no lo quiero punto
en común reunimos a comunidad desde el
matrimonio tradicional y el fbi klaus
para que dialoguen sobre sus diferencias
y similitudes en el lado izquierdo puedo
tener a los miembros el gp en el lado
derecho puedo tener a los conservadores
[Música]
algunas veces me siento incómodo
expresando mis puntos de vista en torno
a la sexualidad
me siento incómoda principalmente porque
el bronce es bueno hay dos chicas quién
es el chico eso rompe el hielo ya que no
se supone que haya un chico por eso
estamos mejor hago lo que puedo para
romper el hielo tratando de ser cómica
lo aprendí como
mecanismo de autodefensa
yo vengo de una comunidad conservadora y
por lo tanto no se hablaba de esto las
personas con las que hablé con mi
familia lo cual es extraño porque salí
del clóset con mis padres porque mi papá
iba a liderar las protestas contra el
orgullo al que mi novio quería ir vaya
entonces
soy un pastor y también soy un líder
comunitario en boyle heights y bien en
esa comunidad hay una gran presencia el
gp así que existe ese miedo de decir lo
que pienso y creo porque los quiero a
todos y no quiero que me hagan a un lado
sólo porque tenga determinados
sentimientos sobre cualquier sobre
cualquier tema sabes
hola solo quería añadir que no son las
creencias con las que a veces tengo un
problema o con lo que las personas
tienen un problema son las acciones de
esas creencias está bien tener creencias
pero si podemos amar dentro de ellas eso
mejoraría nuestras acciones me encanta
que tengamos este tipo de conversaciones
e intentemos abrir una brecha y
construir un puente
algunos pecados son peores que otros
a los ojos de mi ya saben mi dios creo
que cualquier pecado que nos separa de
él porque es santo y puro y al mismo
tiempo creo que hay algunos pecados que
tendrán consecuencias mayores
si estoy de acuerdo con eso para mí
matar a alguien es lo peor sabes además
se relaciona con el aborto tomar la vida
de otro es enorme es mucho puedo
preguntarles esto am ven la
homosexualidad como un pecado sí y si es
así en qué escala no creo que que ser
homosexual o sentir atracción por
alguien del mismo sexo o sea un pecado
creo que es un sentimiento natural pero
cuando empiezas a involucrarte
en un estilo de vida y obras mal eso sí
va en contra de lo que dios nos enseñó
entonces creo que eso sí es un pecado
yo no creo en el pecado porque siento
que ser punitivo con las cosas puede
hacer que te
reprimas e
instintivamente se siente como pero no
actuar como ello es un pecado así se
siente para mi odio ser deshonesta
conmigo misma se siente mal
en algún punto de mi vida me enseñaron
que el sexo está mal
dentro del contexto de que ya sabes el
sexo es malo fuera del matrimonio y así
es como me identifico con la pregunta
tuve una educación religiosa muy fuerte
y terminé haciéndome daño a mí mismo
hice cosas solo para tratar de frenar
los impulsos y cuando finalmente ese día
ellos pensé esto es una manifestación
física del amor es glorioso y hermoso y
cualquier dios que niegue esto no lo
quiero en mi vida porque yo sé que sea
lo que sea esto sé que es algo real
porque el amor es algo natural
sí
sobre tu historia
me entristece escuchar eso que hayas
decidido hacerte daño si a mí también
jaja si todavía yo me aferro a lo que
son mis creencias pero al mismo tiempo
me gustaría que existiera una mejor
manera de hablar con alguien de
procesar y pensar en reconciliarte con
lo que sientes y con lo que te enseñaron
no leíste en las escrituras correcto
quiero decir ese es el problema creo que
hay mucho bagaje cultural en torno al
cristianismo que no es necesariamente
una parte inherente al cristianismo
bíblico
aunque crecí en una familia cristiana no
recuerdo que me dijeran que el sexo
estaba mal o que era malo yo crecí con
la idea de que el sexo es algo hermoso y
se nos dio como un regalo para disfrutar
hay un lugar para el que fue diseñado en
el que disfrutamos y luego hay un lugar
donde es más bien repugnante a los ojos
de nuestro creador no me gusta la idea
de que algo sea repugnante entiendes lo
que quiero decir no me gusta dirías que
el sexo para ti dentro de cierto
contexto es repugnante
si fuera no congenió eso es bastante
viable sí de acuerdo y de acuerdo pero
incluso que con cientos son creo no como
eso a veces no tengo control sobre si es
o no consensuado
las personas deberían respetar los
pronombres de los demás
esto es suficiente
estoy a favor de eso es como si me
identificara con ellos las personas no
lo consideran y creo que tener estas
conversaciones sobre cómo las personas
quieren identificarse es importante para
que podamos seguir avanzando
sí aunque si es como oye si no lo usas
te van a ocultar
así que no soy partidario de estas son
las conversaciones
se trata de ser respetuoso a la policía
de los pronombres
si en mi caso nunca corrijo a las
personas porque a veces me confunden con
un señor que solo me molesta aunque nací
en un cuerpo femenino y soy una ella hay
veces que mis novias me han dicho hay mi
novio estoy aquello sólo por su zona de
confort no quieren lidiar con el estigma
social te sientes cómoda con que te
presenten como un hombre no me molesta
de verdad identidad de mis expresiones
son masculinas llegué a los términos y a
la comprensión de que no necesito
dividir mi cuerpo en diferentes partes
para encajar en la definición de hombre
si te diriges a mí puedes hacer como el
ella o ella o beck y la del pelo lindo
mientras seas respetuoso conmigo sí lo
aceptaré bien me hiciste a un lado
porque es un tema complicado porque es
que el lenguaje es poderoso cuando
alguien que yo creo que es mujer quiere
ser llamado a un hombre quisiera
respetarlo pero sigo creyendo firmemente
que dios creó al hombre y a la mujer y
me gustaría sentarme a hablar con esa
persona antes de inclinarme por uno por
otro lado sabes creo que es mejor
concentrarse en construir una relación
en lugar de simplemente interrogar a
alguien porque eres así sabes lo que
quiero decir con por qué
eeuu va en la dirección correcta en lo
que respecta a la inclusión y la
diversidad
para mí es más bien que la juventud está
siendo más inclusiva y diversa no diría
necesariamente que son las instituciones
creo que los jóvenes están haciendo
avanzar nuestra cultura y es alentador
verlo
no puedo imaginar lo que es no poder ser
quien soy y tener que esconderme creo
que es bueno en ese sentido que las
personas finalmente vivan en un mundo
donde pueden ser quienes son no son
condenadas al ostracismo y pueden ser
incluidas la razón por la que no
interviene es porque ya saben tengo
ciertos valores que vienen de dios por
eso dude sobre si hablar o no hacerlo
saben entiendo pero tengo una pregunta
porque tengo curiosidad de saber en
dónde está la santidad de tu matrimonio
si solo puedes casarte con una mujer
porque tu dios y ella son la relación
ideal quiero saber cómo afecta a eso con
quién podemos casarnos si no creo que
que el trabajo de un cristiano por
ejemplo sea hacer que las personas se
comporten de una forma determinada según
lo que dice la biblia yo no diría
no puedes casarte no puedes casarte con
un chico o con una chica yo diría en
primer lugar dios te ama sabes dios te
ama si así que hablando sobre la
proposición 8 cuando salió la
proposición 8 yo estaba en contra y
pensé que era una tontería muy ignorante
y las iglesias al apoyar la proposición
8 básicamente le dijeron a la comunidad
gay que no les importan tampoco les
importa cómo se sienten lo que ellos
creen que es el amor solo querían
asegurarse de que no se casarán con
quienes ustedes se querían casar somos
adversarios y nos convertimos en
adversarios la iglesia creo perdió una
gran oportunidad de acercarse a las
personas y decirles que las ama las
personas deberían tener derecho a tener
sexo con quien quieran
cualquiera
bien muy bien con solamente pena bien
consensuada con cualquiera si de acuerdo
si con el término cualquiera excepto
niños si como humanos
y como criaturas de un espíritu divino
tenemos derecho a seguir nuestros
instintos y nuestros impulsos sexuales
sin castigarnos por querer a una mujer
oa un hombre así que si cualquiera tiene
derecho a hacer el amor de forma
consensuada
así que la razón por la que no opino y
ustedes estarían de acuerdo conmigo es
que cuando tenía nueve años fui tocado
por un familiar
por eso ya saben no puedo dar un paso al
frente con esa pregunta sé que ustedes
no están de acuerdo con eso ya que desde
un principio dijeron que ya sabes
siempre que sea consensuado y no con
niños pero esa fue mi experiencia
si realmente lo siento por eso no yo
también te entiendo quiero decir me pasó
también ya saben no fue un familiar
gracias adiós sin embargo
siendo un gran problema como para que
incluso aunque sea lesbiana me
preguntara si tenía que ver con ese
instante recordé cosas por eso fue lo
primero que dije porque uno es inocente
y no lo sabe es triste sí
absolutamente
creo en un poder superior
me encantaría escucharlo desde su
perspectiva porque creen en un poder
superior quiero decir es por el hogar en
el que me críe sabes la analogía de no
podemos ver el amor ni el aire pero
siguen ahí
y ya sabes empecé a ir a más misas y a
querer entender exactamente
mis formas de ser a imagen de un creador
mayor entendiendo que yo no era un error
porque hay un poder superior hay algo
que me dio estas bendiciones y no tienen
nada que ver conmigo tienen que ver con
la imagen mayor de las cosas para mí que
fui criado en un entorno religioso muy
fuerte así como no puedo negar esta
parte de mí que es la forma en que puedo
expresar el amor sería deshonesto si
dijera que cuando me senté ore y escuché
y no lo hice ahí no es el momento de los
paganos tienen que parar que no te
equivoques yo también estoy de acuerdo
con algunas cosas que dijeron sí creo en
un poder superior solo que no creo en
uno típico también creo mucho en la
ciencia creo en la gravedad como un
poder superior creo en la entropía en
las cosas que están fuera de nuestro
control y siempre quiero seguir buscando
y cuestionando y tratando de encontrar
tanto amor como sea posible supongo
también creo en los dioses de otras
personas como si creyera en eso para
ustedes y saben lo que quiero decir si
es eso lo que los hace una mejor persona
y los hace sentir más como ustedes y
sentir más amor creo en eso pero no
puedo decir que lo crea para mí porque
no lo sé no quiero poner todos mis
huevos en la misma cesta sí chicos
gracias amigos gracias les agradezco
un placer gracias
jubilee vive intensamente